the shyamu honk ability reversal became
a mnemonic indeed a bizarre satrajit R&D
guru at allmovie it's wonderful to be
imagine what it's like to confront the
men who murdered your brother any idea
about how I got nice I said you made me
that now imagine that the murders are
some of the most powerful and celebrated
members of society free to boast about
their crimes with impunity that's the
premise of Joshua Oppenheimer's new
documentary the look of silence a
companion piece to his previous film the
act of killing the look of silence
confronts the perpetrators of the
Indonesian genocide of 1965 from the
perspective of its victims today who are
determined to learn the unspeakable
truth of their past I spoke with the
film's director Joshua Oppenheimer about
the psychology of mass killers and how
his camera is changing the course of a
nation hi I'm Todd crane and for reason
TV and I'm here talking with Joshua
Oppenheimer about his new movie the look
of silence which is I saw it a few days
ago and I'm still letting it wash over
me I'm still getting over it it is a
very powerful work and Joshua can you
just tell us so just give us a brief
sort of summary but what what what is
this film about for people who don't
know so the look of silence follows the
brother of a victim of genocide but it
said in 1965 Indonesian genocide where
the perpetrators have been in power ever
since and the brother of this victim go
is a man named Adi is an optometrist and
he goes and he confronts all of the men
involved with his brother's murder Walt
and while testing their eyes tries to
get them to take responsibility for what
they've done in the hope of being able
to reconcile with them and what unfolds
is this kind of portrait of the an abyss
of fear and guilt that divides everybody
in this society this sort of portrait of
impunity and what it's like for
survivors to be forced to live and to
rebuild a life surrounded by the still
powerful men
who killed their loved ones what it's
like for them to live essentially for
half a century in fear your main subject
Audie is really an amazing person I
think you could not have had a better a
better lawyer who liked it as an
Inquisitor to ask these really hard
questions I mean basically what he's
doing is he's confronting the very
people who murdered his brother where
did you find someone like that of who of
such a perfect Inquisitor like that in
2003 at the very beginning of my
exploration of the terrible present-day
legacy of the genocide in Indonesia I
was working on a I started this journey
on a remote oil palm plantation where
I'd been helping the had was helping the
plantation workers make a film of their
own back in 2001 2002 and on this in
this region there was one victim whose
name was synonymous with the whole
genocide and that was ah Dee's brother
romli and that's because Raleigh's
murder was the one murder in that region
that had witnesses tens of thousands of
people had been taken to rivers killed
allowed to drift out to sea and their
families never told what happened which
meant that the families couldn't mourn
couldn't grieve because they couldn't
even say that their loved ones had died
they would just say they hadn't come
home yet for decade after decade and
what they were able to do was to talk
about Romney because his murder was
proven there was a body there was there
was a grave and so gradually over the
decades Romney had become a kind of
synonym for the genocide as a whole in
that region and inevitably therefore I
was introduced to Romney's parents and
they wanted me to meet adi saying they
had this son at right after the killings
whom they conceived as a kind of
replacement for their murdered son and
they said if you want to understand what
we lost you must meet
he looks like Brownlee he talks like
Romney acts like Romney he's a kind of
reincarnation of Romney and they called
him to the village and I met this man
who wasn't as afraid as everybody else
because he was born after the killings
hadn't experienced directly the horror
of the genocide in a way he was sort of
from another generation and he was
trying to figure out what happened to
his parents to his family to his
community to make everybody the way they
were everyone was so afraid they hadn't
even told him what had happened and he
latched on to my filmmaking to find
answers to those questions and in a
sense to figure out who he is
I was already 12 years ago and he
started first gathering survivors to
tell me their stories after three weeks
the Army threatened all of the survivors
not to participate he then said don't
give up try to film the perpetrators I
spent seven years filming the
perpetrators him and he would watch
everything I had time to show him that
led to the act of killing and then in
2012 I returned to make the second film
which I always knew I would make I knew
it was always a pair of films and in
returning Adi said I need to confront
the man who killed my brother
at first I said absolutely not it's too
dangerous but then Adi convinced me that
he thought this was the only way that he
could leave hit create a future for his
children where they don't live in fear
of the perpetrators by visiting them by
breaking the silence that he could
somehow because he's not out for a
revenge he could somehow reconcile his
family with his with the murderers of
his brother that that is amazing how and
how did you gain the trust of the
killers as well I mean that I think that
is quite an amazing thing because and I
think as you recognize that it is unique
in the history of documentary in a way
that here you're actually getting people
in power who were genocide or
perpetrators to admit to what they did
and to even gloat about it at first when
Adi told me in 2003 please don't give up
tried if after the army threatened the
survivors not to be in the film he said
please don't give up try to film the
perpetrators I was afraid to approach
the perpetrators at first I was thinking
how will I get them to talk will they
talk I was come devising very neutral
questions that I could ask to slowly
work my way around or what have
during the genocide and I would approach
these purpose the perpetrators trying
that but found to my astonishment that
it wasn't necessary that within seconds
of meeting these men they would open up
about the worst details of the killings
it took if you've seen my first film the
act of killing gradually over time they
open up about their feelings their true
feelings about what they've done they
start talking about their nightmares and
that involved building trust to get them
to talk about their pain and and they
can only do so in a kind of faltering
way because to talk directly about their
pain would be to force themselves to
live with this unbearable guilt to look
in the mirror wake up every morning look
in the mirror and be confronted with the
image of a mass murderer but so to get
them to sort of start revealing these
cracks between how they want to be seen
and how they really see themselves that
took time and you build trust for that
in the same way that you would build
trust with anybody just by being present
and open and trying to understand not
necessarily to excuse trying to
empathize not necessarily to sympathize
but that's just how we human beings
build trust but simply to get the men to
open up which is and to talk about what
they've done it took nothing they would
boast and it is in a way in response to
that and that the impunity that that
evidence is that I made these two films
you do see this incredible change in
these killers and these murderers from
boasting and gloating about their
horrible achievements and then there's
that sudden glimmer of just a very
beginning a faint realization of maybe
this isn't such a great thing maybe this
is actually horrible
are you worried a little bit about
humanizing these people that these
people are going to maybe elicit a
little bit of sympathy from the audience
no because in fact every perpetrator is
human and we have to and if we want to
understand how human beings do this to
each other and how they live with what
they've done we have to try to
understand them as human beings so I
think that not only am I not worried
about humanizing these people that is
the task of these works that doesn't
mean that I'm trying to excuse or elicit
sympathy but I am trying to
the embassy aku when they're talking
about panic alone to Max's young
negative delayed on that be in Olimpica
para una pajara agora TWP retire to hunt
she's doing a heaven apple and you're
absolutely right that in both films in
different ways the perpetrators start to
realize what they've done is wrong
of course they in the in the act of
killing Anwar through repeatedly
dramatizing what he's done he that the
dramatizations become a kind of mirror
in which he sees himself and his
illusions about himself start to crumble
fall into crisis in the look of silence
it's almost more subtle Adi comes to vit
and more and more more more power more
shattering as a result Adi comes and
needs these men and he himself refuses
to look at them as anything other than
human he has this humanizing gaze he
comes to them and this was his point
from the when he first proposed meeting
the perpetrators he said I'm going to
come and I if I go to them not out of
revenge not out of anger showing that
I'm there to listen and if they can
acknowledge what they've done is wrong
then I can forgive they will greet this
he felt as some kind of long
unconsciously hoped for opportunity to
acknowledge what they've done is wrong
to stop their terrible boasting and to
find forgiveness in one of their victims
families and so he thought they would
welcome this and I told him when I
realized we could do this safely I told
him that actually you I think you coming
and seeing them as human as the human
beings that they are will throw them
into crisis because they will then they
will have to meet your humanizing gaze
and they will have to read a will
realize that you you're a human being by
extension your brother whom they killed
was a human being and all of the people
they killed were human beings and
consequently what they've done that
they've done something terribly wrong
that they're and therefore all the lies
they've told themselves to live so that
they can live with what they've done to
justify what they've done will fall into
crisis will start to shatter and you'll
leave them angry defensive
that's right yet defensive and in a way
defenseless kind of naked and they'll
start scrambling for new armor denials
of responsibility amidst threats and
anger and and in that sense just as the
dramatizations in the act of killing or
a kind of mirror in which Anwar the main
character confronts himself Oddie's
questions are a kind of moral mirror in
which these men are forced to see their
own conscience they become terrified not
Avadi not of me but of themselves you
try to get at their motivations and they
oh they give several motivations right
they say well the victims didn't weren't
religious enough right at one point or
they had bad morals and they sort of go
from one leap from one justification to
the next but I can't really I'm trying
to understand I guess what makes
ordinary people commit those kind of
acts what what is their real motivation
underneath all those justifications I
think I think you're asking a very
important question your your subject
you're implying kind of the truth about
my films which is that they are about
the present that it's very difficult to
discern the difference really between a
present day justification a present day
excuse something they've told themselves
afterwards so they can live with what
they've done and what and their
motivation at the time but I think that
I went from working with many
perpetrators from filming with many I
think that we can there's some common
there's some common traits I think first
of all a failure of empathy an
exorbitant selfishness and something we
all are familiar with which is an
ability to be to be incited to
participate in a group which is doing
something that we pry but privately
might feel is wrong I think all of us
have experienced that where there's a
group doing something we're expected to
join the group or were pressured to join
the group and we know that we see the
group doing this we know that what the
group is doing is something we don't
feel comfortable with but we figure well
if everybody's doing it it's probably
okay and I think that kind of incitement
I that if you have that the group if the
group is acting with the blessing of the
state with the blessing of authority
it's
easy to incite people particularly if
you're rewarding them and the
perpetrators I film none of them none of
them felt if they didn't participate
they could be killed or they could be
punished themselves they were promised
promotions they were promised money they
were promised power and prestige and so
they they betrayed their individual
morality to do what they've done and all
of them required at the moment of
killing at the moment of participation
they needed different forms of help so
that they could distance themselves from
the act of killing while they were
killing in the act of killing we hear
that Anwar Congo the main character was
you know smoking marijuana and watching
movies coming out of the cinema
intoxicated by his love of his favorite
film heroes dancing his way across the
street for example after watching an
Elvis Presley musical and killing people
happily the men in the look of silence
would literally be intoxicated they
would drink so that they wouldn't have
to be present in that moment where they
are fundamentally betraying their own
humanity and committing the act of
killing I find that interesting that you
say that because what you're saying is
that individually they are moral people
that they have had a good upbringing
it's this somehow group mentality like
the Stanford Prison Experiment or the
Milgram experiments at Yale that that
sort of brought out this other thing
good primo Levy's said this very
important thing about perpetrators of
the Holocaust he said there may be
monsters among us but they are too few
to worry about what we really have to
worry about are the ordinary people and
every perpetrator I filmed lives their
life into a manic light from this pall
of guilt and shame that follows them
everywhere they go and for the most part
during their waking hours perhaps they
outrun it but when they stop to sleep it
catches up to them and it insinuates
itself into their dreams and they awake
with terrible nightmares and yet because
these men have never been removed from
power they still have available to them
the excuses justifying what they've done
they still have available of Victor's
history that says what they did was
heroic and worth it so they do the human
they do the human thing that I mean you
or I would do
we done something terrible that we that
was eating us up inside but yet but
which the which we'd been told by the
most most August authorities in the land
that we'd been told was right they seek
to take these bitter and rotten memories
and sugar coat them with the sweet
rhetoric of the victors history which
celebrates what they've done and that of
course accounts for the biggest the sort
of most surreal mystery we see in both
of my films which is why are the
perpetrators always boasting about the
most unseemly details things that okay
even if they're proud of this how can
they boast about that well those are
they boast about the most the terrible
deed the grisly details of killing
because those are precisely the most
bitter memories for them to swallow can
you talk about the reception in
Indonesia for a little bit so before the
act of killing came out with very few
exceptions the media was either silent
about what happened or would celebrate
the heroic extermination of the
Indonesian left and that ended with the
act of killing the act of killing you
could say came to Indonesia like the
child in the Emperor's New Clothes
forcing Indonesians to acknowledge
something they've always known which is
the fist reject the present-day regime
is a corrupt violent and built on fear
and that underneath and that it's bait
and it emerges it's based on impunity
for genocide really and that that's
something that the public now is talking
about debating in response to the Oscar
nomination for the act of killing the
government of Indonesia said look we
know what happened in 1965 was a crime
against humanity we know we need truth
reconciled and reconciliation we just
don't need a film to force us to do this
they sort of tried to dismiss the film
but nevertheless they was it was
wonderful because it was the first time
they ever admitted it was wrong and you
can say therefore the act of killing
open the way for the look of silence
which has had a much wider release in
Indonesia it's distributed in fact by
two government bodies the National Human
Rights Commission and the de Carta Arts
Council something unimaginable for the
act of killing which began its life in
secret the first screening in Indonesia
was held in the largest theatre in the
country there were billboards around
around Jakarta announcing the screening
3,000 people
the venue could see 1500 so they put on
two screenings adi came to both
screenings and received a 15 minute
standing ovation now a month later the
film came out around the country with
500 public screenings on the first day
were now at over 3500 screenings and you
can just say that into the space opened
by the act of killing the look of
silence has come also like the child in
the emperor's new clothes
this time pointing out something else
another thing that Indonesians already
knew but couldn't talk about namely the
prison of fear in which every Indonesian
is condemned to raise their children and
it's made it impossible for people not
to address that and not to call for
truth reconciliation and some kind of
justice and that's in fact that debate
the debate which has ensued from the
release of the act of the look of
silence has prompted the government to
introduce a Truth and Reconciliation
bill which what still is woefully
inadequate but is a really important
first step it's a milestone and it's
something that the public the human
rights community can Lobby to have
improved among the many other amazing
things about this movie are the credits
anonymous is credited over and over and
over again gets a credit why did why
there's so many credits for anonymous to
protect Adi and his family safety in the
early wake of releasing the film has
taken a team of five people full-time
and another 20 working in different
capacities part-time and because it's
dangerous to put your name on the
production of my films the team that the
people the Indonesians who helped make
my films are remain anonymous
and these are people who change their
careers to do this work I mean they the
filmmakers human rights lawyers heads of
NGOs university professors who initially
took a six month sabbatical because we
had no idea that this would take a
decade to make these two films and found
that they ended up spending a decade
risking their safety knowing that it was
unsafe to take credit for their work
until there's real change in Indonesia
because they felt it was that important
and so and you see over as the film as
the film and you see that
essentially the entire crew the entire
Indonesian crew remains anonymous I'm
wondering too if you're optimistic about
the future in Indonesia as well because
early on in the look of silence right
you have that unforgettable scene with
the classroom right and you see the next
generation of Indonesians being taught
this theory of the old regime was
wonderful and terrific and the the all
the Communist needs it needed to to be
killed and to be purged the school
curriculum that you see taught in the
look of silence and all actually also in
the director's cut of the act of killing
is still what's taught in Indonesian
schools so in response to the look of
silence the Indonesian Association of
history teachers has come together and
created an alternative history
curriculum that involved four upper
secondary students teaching both of my
films but it says so it's essentially a
way that teachers can say look this is
the official story and now this is the
truth and that's a great that's an
important step forward but the
government needs to change the
curriculum and it's a very it's a good
example of the kind of struggle ahead
that there's real resistance to changing
the official history because if the
government changes the school curriculum
that the state is officially
acknowledging that the wealth and power
of the perpetrators and their oligarch
protegees is a set is not is essentially
the spoils of murder and plunder and
people don't want the most powerful
people in Indonesia do not want to be
exposed as criminals when now they're
seen as the legitimate leaders of the
society so Indonesians are still being
asked to repeat and ask to learn these
lies but now they're saying this is a
lie would you agree is this a film that
only a foreigner could have made yes
absolutely and yet because of my I mean
it would be too dangerous for an
Indonesian filmmaker to do this and very
early on when Adi the other survivors
around him and the human rights
community as a whole after see
encouraging me to film the perpetrators
saw my early footage with them and said
continue to film the perpetrators you're
onto something so important because
anybody who hears the terrible way in
which these people are speaking will be
forced to acknowledge that in an awful
way the genocide hasn't really ended
because the perpetrators are still in
power and
people's lives are still being ruined by
fear when they said that I felt
entrusted by the survivors the human
rights community and Adi to do a work
that they clearly could not safely do
themselves so yes only a foreigner could
make this work but at the same time the
film is making the impact that it's
making inside Indonesia and I would even
argue outside of Indonesia because it's
not made from a foreigners I perspective
it but my collaboration with my
Indonesian crew and my fluency in the
Indonesian language and the years I
spent in Indonesia
I used all of those things to create a
work that would feel for an Indonesian
like a work of Indonesian cinema I
worked one of my anonymous crew members
my he was a production manager
cinematographer or second camera person
sound recordist assistant director he
became my main creative sounding board
just to ensure that every decision in
the shooting and in the editing would
feel wholly authentic to an Indonesian
and that of course makes the film a
mirror for Indonesians it makes it
universal people see the film medon't
see their world being explained to
outsiders they just feel immersed in Adi
and his family's life and I think the
same is true for foreign viewers as if
the film had a kind of screen or layer
of exposition of kind of journalistic or
historical exposition between the viewer
and what's being witnessed where
something things are being explained
there would be a kind of distance and we
would be the film would be inevitably a
kind of like most of the documentaries
that we see especially dealing with
atrocities the film would be a kind of
window onto a far-off phenomenon that we
knew nothing about and cared also little
about being explained to us instead by
making the film wholly Indonesian just
something I could only do as a foreigner
but with the help of an Indonesian crew
to fill the film for even a foreigner
becomes a wholly immersive experience
and it becomes universal it becomes
about all of us you said you you cannot
go back to Indonesia you're it's you're
too fearful at this point yeah and yet
at the same time you've in both of the
films you
really hinted at American involvement in
this in the tragedies I'm wondering if
that affords you an opportunity to talk
more about that in in in the future I
don't know the bulk of the evidence
about what what the United States did
why we did it how we did it remains
classified and I've been working with
lawmakers Senator Tom Udall introduced
to wrestle a sense of the Senate
resolution in reaction to the act of
killing demanding that our saying that
you know 50 years is too long not to
call a crime against humanity a crime
against humanity and if we want there to
be truth and reconciliation inside
Indonesia we had better acknowledge our
own role in his - otherwise we're
hypocrites and he's called for the
declassification of all of the documents
which would reveal exactly what we did
and how we did it so there's a kind of
there's secrecy that's a problem for
talking about what the u.s. role was
enough details have come out that we can
see that that are pretty damning that we
can see that the United States was an
active participant in the genocide the
other thing I'd say is that first of all
we have a perpetrator who's we've just
was just boasted about killing ordering
the killing of 600 people look right at
the camera because he's looking right at
me and I'm right behind the camera
consequently looking right at the
audience and saying that he ought to be
given a cruise to the United States as a
thank you because it was the United
States who taught him to hate and kill
the Communists and then we see an NBC
documentary where we learned that we see
not only that the genocide was reported
as good news but also that they say that
Bali is now more beautiful without the
Communists but also that and it was so
that it was reported in detail in the
United States but it's something
positive but we also learned that good
here a major American corporation is
harvesting the latex for its tires the
soles of our shoes and for our condoms
using slaves taken from death camps
which is precisely what German
corporations did on the periphery of
Auschwitz just 20 years earlier and this
should give any viewer of the look of
silence pause leading us to wonder to
what extent is the so-called straw
destruct the struggle of the so-called
free world against the Communist world
to what extent was that the real reason
for u.s. involvement or is to what
extent was that a an excuse or a ruse or
a pretext for a wholesale and murderous
plunder could you just tell us when is
the look of silence coming out so the
films out already in New York and Los
Angeles and on Friday the 31st of July
it will start coming out around the rest
of the country outstanding I really wish
you the best of luck thanks a lot Josh
thank you for a reason TV I'm Todd crane